having me and thank you Florian for
inviting me
so as florian mentioned I'm a
biomechanical and machine learning
engineer I can abridge the the academic
space into enterpreneurship a couple of
years ago so now we run a startup
but the the point of my talk will be
really to talk to you about a giant
problem they're gonna spend the last
five years trying to solve from very
different angles so back in 2014 I was
working at the World Health Organization
so in public health and it was the first
time I stumbled across the massive
challenge that is childhood pneumonia at
the time I didn't realize it's the
number one killer of children under five
and I found absolutely shocking that in
the 21st century a perfectly treatable
disease takes the lives of 1 million
children and my job at the time
consisted of really looking at the
innovations faced at the you know
googles and Facebooks and so on of the
world pharma companies and academic labs
in trying to map out where is likely
innovation gonna come from to address
this very burning issue so I compiled my
report for the WHL and really reached a
conclusion that we're missing a giant
opportunity to deliver healthcare for
billions of people so my journey then
began in terms of bridging machine
learning AI in community care so what I
mean by community care is figuring out
how do we deliver healthcare diagnosis
in particular in community settings so
outside the cleaning in people's homes
in communities in nursing homes how do
we push the boundaries of healthcare
beyond this kind of facility centered
model that we have around the world so
taking a step back after the Second
World War the WHL the World Health
Organization decided to define health
is a state of complete physical mental
and social well-being which sounds
perfectly aspirational and at the same
time terribly negligent of the majority
of population so if you are an elderly
person and me with multiple chronic
conditions if you're a person with
disability if you're a child working in
a poor country by that definition you
have absolutely no chance of attaining
health in your life so nowadays people
are starting to think a bit more broadly
and accept that really we should be
looking at how do we harness the
innovation we have the policy that we
can write and dictate to really help
people attain health as per their own
circumstances as per their pre-existing
conditions the circumstances within
which they live and so on so really this
is the context of what's kind of the
greatest aspiration in healthcare
universal health care coverage how can
we move to a space where health care is
a human right and everyone regardless of
geography price that background is able
to receive health care where they live
so this in particular was a commitment
the governments around the world signed
up to you in 2018 in Astana in
Kazakhstan to really drive health care
or rather access Universal universal
access to health care around the globe
and the reason why I'm bringing this up
is because the one tool that was
universally highlighted was technology
it's only through technology that we
have the opportunity to reach that
aspiration why am I saying this
so if you look at any healthcare system
around the world you have this situation
we have overwhelming demand so worldwide
eight million people die of perfectly
provide avoidable sorry you have eight
million perfectly avoidable deaths you
have five million children under five
dying every year twenty four percent
growth in the number of chronic
conditions eye conditions the people
continue to live with throughout their
life
and if you take this healthcare
healthcare system for example in just a
decade we'll double the number of
appointments that a GP has to provide
per person so all that's telling us is
the tools we have at hand can definitely
not meet the demand that we're facing
today what we have on the supply side is
a massive gap of doctors so worldwide
we're missing 7 million doctors so even
if we started training 10 times as much
as many as we're training today we're
still not gonna meet the demand and at
the end of the day if we wanted to use
the tools we have at hand at the moment
it would cost us another 400 billion
annually to deliver universal health
care service and this will only get
worse as our populations grow in age at
the same time I am a technology geek so
I went into biomedical engineering in
love with hardware all the opportunities
the medical devices bring so whenever I
see another medical wearable I
definitely get very very excited about
the promise that that holds and there is
a lot of advancement on that front and
so if you look at video consultations
chatbots
wearable devices that's definitely kind
of bringing the boundaries of healthcare
beyond what we were we have over the
last decade but even if you managed to
manufacture the best wearable in the
world and put it into the hands of every
single person around the world you're
still stuck with the same challenge
which is what do you do with all that
data you can use very simple digital
thresholds which is how our system
operates at the moment is your heart
rate too high too low is your blood
pressure going about above certain
thresholds to try and kind of filter all
that information that's gonna start
hitting doctors but all of that is sure
geographically scalable but terribly
terribly I'm specific so if you're an
elderly person the lives with three
conditions very complex conditions these
thresholds are not going to get us
anywhere or you can try and somehow
magically manufacture doctors so when
you told you we're missing 7 million so
that's not going to get
but that's the best we have at the
moment in terms of precision medicine I
complex evaluation of all the health
parameters that quantify one's health to
reach decisions which brings me to my
entrepreneurial journey so I set a
feverish with this mission of bridging
this this gap empowering dr. quality
detection of complex conditions at scale
and in particular starting with
respiratory conditions so going back to
the start of my story with spiritual
conditions because of this one massive
problem pneumonia that currently kills 1
million children but also creates
massive problems for our elderly people
so if you look at countries like India I
nearly have 160,000 children that die of
the disease and this cost the health
care system 1 billion pounds and at the
other age and income extreme we have in
the UK the number one driver of
avoidable hospitalization is the exact
same disease costing the NHS one 1.7
billion pounds there is also a
geographic inequality in in the way that
disease burden is distributed
particularly for children 99 percent of
mortality is concentrated in low
resource settings so how we tackling
this issue
we are trying to bridge the gap between
what's currently a facility based health
care system and communities by bringing
point of care devices so digital
stethoscopes pulse oximeter is medical
wearables all of this hardware that's
becoming more and more prolific and can
be put into the hands of very minimally
trained users we're combining that with
a very intuitive mobile application so
that you can have carers community
health care workers even family members
take measurements whenever necessary to
capture all that information that
currently is only captured by let's say
a GP in this country or highly trained
dog
in another setting then the role of Rai
and where I play plays an important role
is in the interpretation of those
measurements so these wonderful devices
do exist on the market at the moment
them but the majority of them are
created for doctors so if you look at
any digital stethoscope it's meant for a
very highly trained doctor to use it in
a hospital and then interpret the signal
that it generates based on decades of
training that they've received in their
clinical practice we are automating this
with machine learning and then the final
piece of the completes the puzzle is
really figuring out how do we share this
information in an actionable way with
the health system so that we can
continue delivering health care in a in
a very evidence-based way so just to
give you a bit more visualization of
what that looks like if you haven't seen
a digital stethoscope that's the device
at the bottom the posts oximeter the one
on top is the device that goes on your
finger measures your heart rate oxygen
saturation and if you've ever been to a
hospital you definitely had one of those
put in your finger
in terms of our mobile application it's
basically designed in a way where the
user needs to know where to place the
device and just follow that simple
procedure without needing to interpret
anything and at the end of the
examination they given an actionable
insight so depending on the setting it
could be take the patient to a hospital
or a very kind of precise identification
of a condition let's say an asthma
exacerbation which requires an any trip
and let me just give you a kind of a
very practical example so sticking with
childhood pneumonia it's kind of the
first problem that we started working on
our first trial was in 2017 in India
with 1300 children and really the goal
there was how do we empower an existing
workforce to deliver precision medicine
so in the case of India there is 1
million health care workers that
currently service the population these
are people that have
high school education and currently
conduct very observational tasks so
they'll go around the communities and
try and spot different markers of
disease observational II in order to
identify the kids that need to go to
hospital what we did was provide them
with a mobile application and our
sensors so that within ten minutes they
can collect the data required to make a
more evidence-based evaluation and based
on the success of that program we
received international funding to scale
to 10,000 children so that's the program
we're currently running in India with
partners just to give you because you're
all people that love data just to give
you a bit of a flavor of performance
diagnostic performance so we
demonstrated that we can be 97% accurate
when it comes to triage namely
identifying kids that have respiratory
issues and 85 percent accurate when it
comes to you diagnosing pneumonia the
reason that's very important is because
the gold standard and the outcomes we
trained against our x-rays and blood
tests in a high-end hospital so it can
be 85 percent accurate compared to a
very very expensive procedure in a
facility that most children don't have
access to and this is just a short video
that basically visualizes what the
process looks like so it starts with a
questionnaire that most GPS will ask you
all the questions they would ask you
when you go to their practice there are
a couple of observational things like is
the child lethargic do they have noisy
breathing then there is a quick
connection to the two devices it's a
wireless and then the examination
experience basically consists of the
healthcare worker placing in this case
the digital stethoscope on these four
locations at the front of the chest
holding the stethoscope for 12 20
seconds at each location to capture the
data and then moving on we have a way of
shortening the examination if the child
is crying because that's very
frustrating for everyone involved
so rather than 9 measurements they need
to only capture five and at the end of
this they also take a temperature
reading with a conventional thermometer
so at that step they submit all the data
for analysis which is currently done on
a cloud we would look through all the
questionnaire inputs the device inputs
and then give them a recommendation of
whether or not they need to take the
child to to a doctor which in the Indian
scenario is a hospital right so getting
to the part that everyone's gonna be
interested in if I was a rather long
introduction but setting is very
important where does the AI fit in so
every one of these sensors that we use
generate incredibly noisy signals we
only work with medically approved
devices so that does give us some level
of standardization so you wouldn't work
with a wellness wearable that doesn't
have a certified output but the
challenge that this still presents is
how do you how do you attract things
that doctors are currently empirically
trained to look out for so to give you
an example with the status curve they
look for about five different markers
that they listen to you there isn't
really a database of what these markers
are it's all on the on-the-job training
so you take about 10 to 15 years to
become a very exceptional pulmonologist
and all of that is done through you
being in a hospital shadowing someone
that's extremely experienced and picking
up that knowledge on the go so our
challenge is to standardize that process
extract conventional things like vital
science oxygen saturation respiratory
rate heart rate but also more advanced
things like these lung sounds that I
mentioned and then once we've kind of
populated this multitude of disease
markers our next challenges how do we
link those to a specific diagnosis of a
condition so sticky with my previous
example how do we diagnose pneumonia
that typically requires an x-ray and the
blood test in a highly trained
pulmonologist with just the noisy
signals that we can capture in a
community setting
so just to dig a little bit deeper on
that first part of translating noisy
signals into evidence-based disease
markers so this is the digital
stethoscope all of you have seen a
stethoscope there is absolutely nothing
different other than this is digitized
so that you can actually record the
signal that it outputs so in an in an
ideal world this is how it would
function you would have the signal
captured in a clinical setting then you
get a doctor to listen through it look
through it until you hear I hear
wheezing and here I hear crackles these
are the different markers and the names
that they've given them and then you
train your beautiful model to identify
these markers in an automated way sounds
wonderful and if you dig a little bit
deeper and get into let's say the
libraries that you can find online for
clinical training they will show you
crackers looks a little bit like this
and wheezing looks a little bit like
that and broken breathing a little bit
different so all of you to do data
science you can see that there are quite
a few patterns you can pick up and then
hopefully detect it with your algorithm
this holds incredible opportunities when
it comes to improving access to
specialist terminology pulmonology of
evaluation the improvement of precision
diagnosis as well as enabling early
detection for these conditions and
there's always a but so the but is when
you do that in real-life settings you
have very noisy environments and very
very noisy signals you have the
complexity of annotation and a terribly
unreliable got gold standard and I'll
give you examples of all of those
challenges so starting with the noisy
signals so our data is collected in
Indian slums plenty of background noise
often people chatting in the home about
whatever they're going to cook for
dinner you have the community health
care worker chatting to the parent the
community health care worker chatting to
the child trying to appease them because
they're getting really impatient during
the examination
so loads of talking
loads of crying if the child is getting
impatient loads of background noise and
often poor contact because these are not
ideally trained users so minimally
trained users so the best they can do is
hold the sensors in place but they're
not doctors they haven't spent 15 years
to appreciate how much pressure they
need to exert and so on so one of the
things we've done is develop an
algorithm that classifies whether or not
a signal is good enough for further
interpretation the next thing we're
doing is classifying noise so that we
can give people very actionable output
like please don't talk during this
recording or you need to calm down the
child right so talking about annotation
and unreliable goat standards we had
seven experts from the UK and India
annotate our data and we found
absolutely terrible agreement in their
annotation so if you're familiar with
flies copper it basically gives you an
indication of how good the kind of the
correlation between different labels is
in they'd said it was just about slide
in between the seven terminology experts
and there's some like shocking insight
in here if you have a look in that first
row so crackles is the most indicative
lung sound of pneumonia across the users
annotating the exact same data set some
of them think that point four percent of
the data have crackles in them others
think that ten point six percent of the
day to have crackles so we're not even
talking about slight differences they
just listen to and identify completely
different things so the way we address
this was moving away from these very
empirically developed gold standards and
looking for more kind of cool Asetek
markers or acoustic markers of disease
so training against the overall outcome
which is the presence or absence of a
condition like pneumonia and then I then
to find different different acoustic
signatures that we can correlate
directly with the outcome the very
specific model we used was a DN n DN n
hmm if anyone's interested we can have a
very detailed discussion about this
right so this is all to do with
identifying markers of disease and the
next challenge we have is once we've
identified them how do we reach a final
diagnosis and again the opportunities
are immense we can diagnose disease
early we can improve the precision of
diagnosis and most importantly or at
least the thing I'm most passionate
about is prevent avoidable deaths
particularly in communities that
otherwise don't get access to your
diagnosis but again that doesn't come
without challenges so two major ones
that we're tackling data sparsity and
model generalizability so when it comes
to data sparsity there are many many
many hospital datasets that you can get
access to and that's how I started my
research in this space in academia
getting access to hospital datasets
developing models for diagnosis they
work beautifully publishing getting
really excited about 97% accuracy and
then the moon the moment you take these
models to a community setting you
realize they don't generalize because
nothing looks the same in a community
the data is very very noisy patients
look very different because it's
potentially earlier on in the disease
evolution and also that the sensors you
would use are not what the hospital uses
normally so this here is a comparison
between three data sets we've worked
with across different geographies so the
first one being a hospital they'd said
in The Gambia the second one a community
data set with our sensors and the third
one a hospital data set from India as it
as you can see you can't even say that
the difference is it driven by geography
so even within the to you Indian data
sets and these are all statistically
power datasets by the way I should have
mentioned that the differences are just
huge and just as a clarification so what
you're looking at the
by the plot is basically incidents of
different symptoms for children with
pneumonia so terribly variable if you
want to dig a little bit deeper and
start will start looking at pattern so
this is a t-sne plot of pneumonia cases
across these different datasets were
basically trying to cluster and use
unsupervised learning to establish any
patterns in the data in the different
pneumonia cases you can see that their
star is between certain groups that
coincide with geographical separation so
if you look at the plot that says data
set source you can see that the blue
dots kind of cluster on their own but
then you have this giant cluster the
basic has blue grey and brown so all of
them are pneumonia cases from different
data sets why the other pneumonia cases
then just a complete outliers and don't
have a mixture of a mixture of kind of
sources there's absolutely no logic so
we started digging into the symptomatic
distribution so is it driven by let's
say natural physiological differences
between populations some for example
some populations like South India sorry
South Asian populations have naturally
elevated heart rates is it driven by age
groups there isn't really an answer to
that other than the variability and then
the underlining kind of comorbidities we
have behind the disease quite
substantial so the way we've we've kind
of come up with a framework to overcome
all of these challenges is to move away
from trying to replicate what the
clinical profession does at the moment
and preserve their kind of overall
evidence base in terms of outcomes but
use machine learning to generate better
process
is to reach those outcomes so going back
to the example I gave you with the
digital stethoscope rather than trying
to replicate their labels of crackles
wheezing grunting and so on we're trying
to do is identify patterns in the data
that agree with their diagnosis of
pneumonia based on a x-rays and blood
tests and so on and you can generalize
that across symptoms you can generalize
this across populations right just to
give you an interesting ROC curve
apologies for the way you want to be
that's meant for a different audience
not a everyone knows our rockers works
probably here so just comparing our
basically performance against everything
else that's out there is an option you
have the orange dots which guidelines so
these would be things that the World
Health Organization and UNICEF have
community health care workers using at
the moment around the world very
sensitive but very own specific and then
the blue and green dots are your doctors
in this country for example so we had
seven different doctors annotate the
data and what you can see is exactly
what you experienced here so you go to
the doctor they kind of saying well it
could be pneumonia it could be just the
cold why don't you go home and come back
if it gets worse so very very specific
but terribly and sensitive insensitive
and what we are able to do with the
approach that I described it's kind of
bridge both words have the sensitivity
of these guidelines and the specificity
of doctors right the last thing I wanted
to mention are a few kind of
opportunities but also challenges around
deploying this approach in low resource
settings as I mentioned the the kind of
settings we work with a way that the
moment our urban slums this one in
particular is in Mumbai and the
opportunities this whole this holds a
huge both in terms
they designs and machine-learning so
very exciting challenges by capturing
data that doesn't exist off the shelf
that comes with a lot of excitement when
it comes to developing models they're
not sick autos but also there is an
opportunity to deliver primary health
care in a setting that doesn't have an
established primary health care system
at the moment and the bottom line is
powering universal healthcare coverage
right skipping to the challenges so one
of the bigger lessons we learned was
never make assumptions before you've
tested them very extensively so even
though originally we tested our
technology kind of alongside the main
streets of the slum and connectivity was
reliable enough the moment you try to
cover the whole that's the geography we
cover we realize there many many dark
patches so what this picture shows you
is a slum population in Mumbai right
next to the biggest dumping ground in
Asia and it's divided in certain regions
for planning reasons but this has 1.2
million people living in it we're
currently covering it with about ten
health care workers the need to move
around test different children and then
take them to the doctor if they need to
if you have patchy connectivity at the
end of that screen where I showed you a
recommendation you can't get anything
because the models at the moment live on
the server so what that's triggered is a
whole new exercise of figuring out how
we deploy models on device particularly
models that were developed to be quite
computationally intensive so really
eager to talk to anyone that has
expertise on that front then you can
share knowledge and the second challenge
is we work with very minimally trained
users so what that means is you can end
up with a lot of bad data and not
actionable data so one of the big
engineering exercises that we're going
through is providing very actionable
feedback so that you can straightaway
know whether all the measurements have
been captured good enough for a
diagnosis
just a very short note so throughout
this talk they mainly talk about talked
about child health we're doing the exact
same thing for elderly people in this
country so if anyone's interested in
that space and happy to have a lot of
conversations slightly different
challenges because we're looking at
longitudinal monitoring so rather than
diagnosis based on an examination is
monitoring someone over time and then
identifying complications for chronic
conditions yeah I can't talk about India
not finish with a Gandhi quote so be the
change you want to see in the world
that's what we believe as a company and
if that's something that you're
interested in and aspire to do with your
work I'll be very delighted to talk to
you thank you very much
[Applause]
I've been told that we can have
questions and answers is that true yeah
yeah right there are some microphones
apparently thank you very much for the
talk in case somebody wants to help you
is there like any public data or open
source libraries where you can
contribute public data then we open
source yeah like that you use and
somebody can like creates like try to
create a better model or just contribute
to a package like in terms of so at this
stage we don't open sources data having
said that we are very interested in
collaborations so if anyone's interested
to work with us that could be we are
hiring so that could be the were
permanent way but also in terms of
advisers and consultants any any format
is possible so if if someone is actively
interested in this space more than happy
to you to discuss that
hey thanks you talk that's really
inspiring and I'm just curious so are
you collecting all the data that you get
from all the senses and sending it to
the cloud where you discarding some of
the data look like on whatever device
yeah great question you should have
asked me that question once ago because
originally we were sending all the data
to device didn't realize that's a
terribly stupid idea so at the moment
storing your own device before we send
it to the server how did you see the
times you have disease because you can't
you might have a population s scenario
that some disease might be a lot better
some disease the signals might mean
something else
you know doctors normally said they say
50% chance of this 45 percent days so it
depends on context and time of year
whatever I mean so you're measuring
certain symptoms but these things might
mean something else
in depending the time the year or or
there is some some disease that's
currently prevalent so they're not you
can't do one-to-one mapping between
prime minister disease might meet
something else so there are a couple of
things that feed into that one is the
seasonality definitely a huge issue
that's why we run larger trials that
span across 12 months because you get a
lot of seasonality the other part of
this is the gold standard outcome is
absolutely crucial that's why we need to
run control trials and we have
clinicians setting the final diagnosis
that we train against as well so you can
have a lot of diagnostic overlap at the
end of the day there should be a right
or wrong diagnosis that a clinician can
reach in a hospital so we work in
partnership with hospitals to basically
annotate that data in real-time I think
there's one at the front oh sorry
hi this is amazing by the way
honestly I'm curious because you chose
the cloud if you encountered any
blockers be it from government or some
kind of laws because it's data about
patients and how did you how did you
solve it because about I didn't he said
Oh patients people generally yeah I mean
and a lot of corporations when it comes
to clients or especially health data
it's a no-no for going to the cloud some
very curious yeah yeah
so we didn't we haven't encountered
pushback but that's because we accept
that we need to move more slowly to the
conventional startup in terms of getting
the ethical approvals in place and
really ensuring that everything's done
in a kind of a secure and compliant way
so in the case of India in it takes six
months to get an ethical approval and
you need to be very kind of
evidence-based in terms of where you
store the data what you do with it the
other aspect of that is we are going
through C certification to be a medical
device so again a slow process but one
that that's worth doing if you actually
want to have something actionable that
people can take into their medical
practice but you know if you can look at
them as blockers or you could look at
them as opportunity to do things right
it yeah it's a tedious process but one
that's worth doing
hey I was just wondering if you if
you've thought of doing any kind of
generative modeling in this space I mean
like you know looking at what kind of
spectrograms you would expect your model
to be give you that you know the most
the highest score - for example I mean
and maybe you could produce like a new
gold standard because this is the thing
that's most likely to correlate with
with the output yeah yeah brilliant
question we are doing some of this
particularly around the acoustic
analysis so if you take something what
should be incredibly conventional like
with spiritual rate like everyone's
heard of our spiritual rate or doctors
use it there is no gold standard for
this that - at the moment and both of
them are flawed one is watching the
child's chest and counting the other one
is listening to your stethoscope and
counting and if you ask different
doctors to do that exercise you get very
different answers so there is definitely
definitely an element of that we're
doing the challenge is you kind of need
to do a bit of both because you can't
just leap frog and tell the clinical
profession this approach of doing things
it's totally wrong so you need to figure
out how you replicate what they're doing
but then also give them a comparison of
hey we could do it we could be doing
this in a much better way so in our case
it's just yeah a balancing act of
demonstrating both in an evidence-based
way thank you much
yeah great talk in your your video you
did the the test and then it just came
up with a recommendation to take it to a
hospital
does it provide any sort of explained
ability or information to the doctor
once they've got to ask but or do they
have to repeat the test so all over
again themselves yeah thanks a lot for
that question I kind of whiz through it
because I wasn't sure how much context
people want to hear yes so the other
thing we have is a web portal Atlas
meant for patient management so when the
child reaches the doctor the doctor can
pull up that case and see what the child
looked like in the community that's a
way for us to capture the ghost and the
Nana tation as well as the provide
function and extra function for the
doctor to be able to make more
evidence-based decisions otherwise he
just sees the child there for three
minutes and has to reach a diagnosis
somehow
and there is one more do you detect any
heart problems such like there is i mia
or anything like this yeah great
question um so at the moment we have
focused on respiratory conditions and
that kind of goes back to the previous
question because of regulation and so
our goal is to get certified as a
medical device for respiratory
conditions we we do capture data they
also contain some valeriy information
for house heart sounds and then heart
conditions but it would be just a lot to
do to try and get certified for two very
different spaces at the same time great
thank you very much
[Applause]